katie is with us in Ohio hi Katie how
are you I'm good how are you this better
than I deserve what's up so I am a
graduating college senior hey what's
your degree in communications good in
May with and so I've been taking out
student loans and I'll be in a total of
27 thousand dollars in debt when I
graduate and I do but I don't think the
payment starts until six months after
but I'm just wondering what you think I
should do to pay it off as soon as
possible while still hopefully trying to
save money and then I wouldn't the same
function I would just pay it off as soon
as possible
there's got all the money that I make
towards it yes everything live like I
live like a college student okay
like your bro not like you're not like
you're not like you're a newly graduated
very cool young adult with a cool new
job don't act like that okay act like
you're a stupid but broke college
student don't spend any money do you
have any idea what you're gonna do for a
career I work in marketing okay any
ideas where have you looked at jobs or
anything yet I started looking I'm
currently interning at two different
places right now
any guesses on what you think your
income is going to be on entry-level
marketing position the host is 40,000
okay
all right and would you make this year
this year total I just started I started
it during the summer making like 9c an
hour at one internship and then 15 at
the other okay and you're working like
20 hours or something yeah yeah okay so
this year this year you made like twelve
thirteen thousand dollars right yeah
okay so if you lived on twelve or
thirteen thousand this year and you make
forty thousand next year and you live
like you live this year you can pass
27,000 real fast she did that math yeah
your income goes from
13 to 40 but you're out Co out go does
not because you don't change your
lifestyle Roger you live like a broke
person okay not a person with a new job
and newly graduate from college and
because let me tell you what people do
when they graduate from college they
think that they're making 40 and they
act like they're making 80 and they go
buy a new car and we're in an apartment
they can't afford and fill it up with
brand-new furniture from rooms there
they went right don't do that crap okay
get you a nice leather couch from a used
used one from a garage selling the rich
into town for a hundred bucks or 50
bucks and load that thing in there and
get you a cheap little refrigerator and
don't you have a life for the first year
and you probably can pay off these
student loans in the first year in one
year yeah Wow okay should I start paying
it off while I'm in college
no just let's get don't add any more
debt while you're in college yeah finish
if you got one go let's do that that is
your first goal okay but here's the
thing okay $40,000 a year is um 3,500
bucks a month okay right and if you put
$2,000 a month on the student loan it'll
be gone two thousand times fourteen it's
gonna be twenty-seven twenty-eight
thousand okay so 14 months later if you
do $2,000 a month and you got that
leaves you 1,500 bucks a month to live
on cheap rent cheap everything no life
and fourteen months later fourteen
months later you're not cool but you're
freakin debt-free good cool there you go
now we have a whole new definition of
cool I think that that means that you're
a grown-up if you have a right
definition of gold a cool good job well
done yeah I mean I mean 54 year olds who
aren't grown-ups by the way and their
definition of cool is driving a car they
can't afford going on vacations they
can't afford
so their friends on Instagram are
impressed and they're 54 years old
making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year and freaking broke and
that's not cool that's lying that's
putting forth an image that isn't
fraudulent it is not true so you can do
this you
can do this you can do this I'm proud of
you I think you're gonna do this give
her a copy of I'm putting a whole copy
of a Total Money Makeover show her how
to do it
call me back and you do your debt-free
scream when you get out of debt I only
hear from you